lors du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle leur champion nicolas
dupont aignan a obtenu 4,34 % des voix
dans le département malgré son alliance
éphémère lors du second tour avec le
front national le parti a présenté des
candidats dans toutes les
circonscriptions comme sylvia cantaluppi
dans la 11e qui brigue le poste de
benoît hamon le député sortant son but
prolonger le programme de son champion
la moralisation de la vie politique donc
sur des élus sur un renouvellement et
des élus propre et avec des casiers
judiciaires vierges
bien évidemment et une un comportement
qu'ils soient citoyens et qui se croient
pas au dessus de la loi et des forces de
l'ordre
ce n'est pas la première fois que sylvia
cantaluppi se présente elle était déjà
candidate en 2012 et avait obtenu 0 68%
des voix pour d'autres candidats c'est
la première fois comme joël bosch
candidat dans la 10e circonscription des
yvelines
il partage les idées de nicolas dupont
aignan depuis 2014
son thème de campagne la solidarité moi
ce que je pleure beaucoup celle à
l'augmentation de la pauvreté en france
donc des on a de plus en plus de
chômeurs plus en plus de pauvres
solidarité indépendance de la france ou
encore donner la parole au peuple ses
candidats souhaite s'imposer comme la
vraie droite républicaine
en france ces idées qui ont séduit
emmanuel bojan candidat dans la première
circonscription des yvelines
l'idée c'est de pouvoir représenter une
droite sociale une droite humaniste une
droite gaulliste qui ne soit pas à
géométrie variable est prête à renier
ses valeurs après avoir longuement
critiqué emmanuel macron avant le
premier tour et si être beaucoup rallié
après le après le premier dans la 12e
circonscription c'est fabien mettay qui
représentera debout la france dans le
fief de david douillet dans la 2e
circonscription c'est françoise forette
qui tentera d'obtenir le poste de pascal
thévenot dans la troisième
circonscription c'est thibaut tournier
qui représentera le parti de nicolas
dupont aignan